So to prepare for watching these lectures, of course, you'll be just to hit the play button
but actually it would be helpful, if you actually do some reading.
And as I said earlier, there's optional reading and you'll see this going forward
after each lecture and a Starup Owner's Manual pp. 1-50 or in the strategy volume if it's an E-book.
And in Business Model Generation pp 14-49, completely optional.
But what's available for free is if you want to get a feel of the core strategy
how we're trying to teach this and how we teach this in real life,
you could go to steveblank.com category/Lean LaunchPad or just click on the link.
You could also look at other student's presentations and we have our students
make 2-min quick time videos which are summaries of their presentations as well
and you could see those at steveblank.com/slides but if you want to actively engage in the class,
your first real homework is download that Osterwalder canvas and using yellow stickies,
take a shot at actually filling out all your hypothesis on the business model canvass.
It's okay if you're just guessing because the whole class is about
how do you turn those guesses into facts.
So get ready, download the canvas, put on those yellow stickies, and then looking at those boxes,
start figuring out who would you call on and who would you contact to start testing those hypothesis
and take a look for the first week at your value proposition and customer segment box.
Who would you want to talk to, to validate whether your idea about what features are important
and who would you talk to, to validate that these are customers you want to go after
and we're just getting you ready for the work you're going to do after the next lecture.
See you soon!